(upbeat music)
(ambulance siren)
(bottle spray)
(man gagging)
(gasps)
- Dad! You woke
up from your coma!
- Oh my god, what did I miss?
- Well I'm really
glad you asked,
because I got into Har--
- Movies!
You gotta tell me about
the movies that I missed.
I've been in a coma a long time.
- Um, I just saw Spider-Man.
- Another one with
Andrew Garfield?
- No, it's a reboot
with Tom Holland.
- A three-boot?
We get it.
His uncle's dead,
what else is out?
- Um, I don't know.
Kong?
- Kong, King Kong?
That stinker with Jack Black?
They made another one? Ugh.
- No, it's a second reboot.
And then the next one he's gonna
like, fight Godzilla, okay?
- They're three-bootin'
King Kong and Godzilla?
Jesus Christ, we get it!
They hate helicopters.
What else came out?
- The Mummy! Now will you
please just listen to me?
- The Mummy with Brendan Fraser?
- No, with Tom Cruise, okay?
They three-booted that too.
Are you happy?
- Never, Tom Cruise?!
Who reboots a movie
with an older actor?!
- Just shut up!
I got a scholarship to
an Ivy League school!
Aren't you proud of me?!
Look, I even bought you this
sweatshirt, you ass face!
- It's not personal,
I'm very proud of you.
Thank you for the sweatshirt!
I've just been in a
coma a very long time,
and I gotta know what
else is three-booted!
I hate three-boots,
what else came out?!
(breathing heavily)
- Lego Batman,
okay, Lego Batman.
- Another Batman, no!
(crying)
- And Justice League is
coming out this year too.
- Rebooting two Batmans
at the same time?!
My god, we get it! He's rich!
(heart monitor beeps quickly)
(heart monitor flatlines)
- Oh Dad, oh god, geez.
- Stand back! Clear!
(upbeat music)
(chest paddles thump)
- Oh no, no, two's enough
'cause he hates three-boots.
- Hey, Hardvard!
I went there too!
- Oh, no way!
- Yeah, near Bonston!
- Alumni!
- Yeah, I love their
Same Adams Beer.
- Oh yeah, me too, so good.
- Too much.
- Yeah.